[Music]
in sneaky snake news sneaky snake
submitted by Zam vlog okay seems long I
used to say that all the time oh yeah
you don't do that anymore
forgot about it bring it back Sam's whoa
Tesla is suing an employee that Elon
Musk claimed committed sabotage against
the company whoo what did I do
oh do they fill up the batteries with
water or something dude if Elon Musk
sues you that means he's for real for
real yeah cuz he doesn't have time for
that [ __ ] he doesn't even need to sue
you you know what's dope about him he
actually responds personally to a lot of
customer service requests and tweets I
see him on Twitter I tweeted him he did
twit [ __ ] me me neither I asked him for
a [ __ ] bionic arm that shoots
missiles okay I told you something a
little more realistic mine is realistic
because he believes in singularity and
I'm like the only way we're gonna [ __ ]
up these robots is to get started today
with a robot by having becoming the
robot - hmm I just ask for a single
person driving vehicle that has a long
electric mile range so it's like you
know like in LA if you just want to go
if it's just you and you want to grab
something just a one-person vehicle with
like a decent trunk space that's what I
want
Oh tire so it's like you could have
their big car and if you really just
wanted to have a small car that you can
travel around it's not a smart car smart
cars like that no smart cars are
bitch-made and they don't go that far
and they're [ __ ] slow and they don't
have trunk space either so I just won a
cockpit just one seater in the middle
and then you have decent trunk space so
just cut the Tesla in half whatever you
have kind of sort of but not really it's
gonna look like the Jetsons car yeah
kind of you know it's gonna look like
yeah watch you [ __ ] the Oscar Mayer
wiener car there you go what does that
look like no it's kind of huge
my choice ice you know it's gonna look
like it's gonna look like that side pod
we're like the [ __ ] on a motorcycle
you're on the side but it's going to
have good front space and the cool thing
is if you leave the real estate for the
one person only it's gonna be way more
comfortable cuz you're not sharing it
with another seat on the side so you
want to add more to the pollution that
we already have no it's an electric car
so you want a scooter but you don't want
to look like a [ __ ] kind of sort of
yeah you ride a scooter don't mean
you're a [ __ ] I know you so basically
you just call all Vietnamese people
[ __ ] country and Taiwan because
everyone rides a scooter how so Italians
oh yeah guess you don't like pizza do
you babies go throw me under the bus
like that Tesla filed a lawsuit against
a former employee apparently this former
employee was due to get a promotion but
he was passed up for the promotion he
got angry so he committed sabotage
against the company where he hacked
software on the computers of three
colleagues and he would continue to
export company data after he left the
company through those three computers so
he was giving this sensitive information
elation sure he also changed parts of
the company's manufacturing operating
system code that's a huge [ __ ] deal
he should what if people got hurt from
mistakes like oh the musk is nice don't
people usually just like get them
assassinated like Oh car accident with
his type of money huh yeah like people
like it for a billionaire it's just
those people just disappear but like
what's better like putting him in jail
or taking all of his money for the rest
of his life
no I would I would like kill him I'd
rather kill him then I would put his
family in jeopardy too okay well well
that's how you hurt them yeah you [ __ ]
up by marrying a [ __ ] by using the
order of events in which you place two
doesn't makes oh I'm sorry we would we
would put his family in jeopardy first
and then and then hurt his family in
front of him while he died slowly yeah
you know I'll give him a free trip to
like the Swiss Alps and when they go in
the gondola ride on the cable it just
magically snaps somehow and it swings
like a pendulum and smashes against the
mountain and they all [ __ ] splatter
and it looks like
thrilling before they die yes I'll be
vomit no no no they look like vomit
after they get smashed like actually
batter like chunky pancake batter that
made my stomach turn in yeah but we're
in the my state of a billionaire yeah
who has all the power in the world they
can make anything happen
regular David would never hurt us what
if he wants to spray poop spell all over
the place mmm oh yeah that guy's the boy
I think the best thing is the
combination of everything so you have
your own little island right where you
kidnap them and keep them there and then
you have it all they do is sit down and
watch a TV of all their family members
slowly getting taken away and tortured
in front of them because of their love
and then when they're done with that
then every single day a different limb
gets pulled off of their body they
should start a show called a inch a day
and then so what it is so you just have
like your wife your wife and your kid
and you have a knife and it just saws in
an inch and you just leave the knife
there for 24 hours
oh ouch and it just goes in an inch a
day so you probably only have like maybe
like five four or five inches five days
to live life is all there car this guy
must have done something really bad in
today I want to make you're mad no it's
not mad but that's what they sure yeah
it was that type of money we're still
working yeah you won't give us that type
of money
it's my hands no that's why I'm so
jealous of kim jeong-hoon he could do
whatever he was so friendly I know he
looks like a Pillsbury Dough Boy with a
slick back 1990 hair yeah so what's
going on with mr. Muskies how much money
is he suing them for you guys are
personal friends just going on with
muskie how much money and they're not
really going to much deters just like
we're about to suit his [ __ ]
let's tell the world no so there was a
an email that musk sent to Tesla
employees and that's what was really and
so in that email talking about the fact
that the guy
promotion what he exactly did but he
does say that the full extent of his
actions are not clear yet is just what
we know is what he's admitted so forth
you imagine me and that salty over not
getting a promotion like that's mad
corny though it's a entitle little [ __ ]
Yeah right like this guy already made a
lot of money and then he wanted more
money unless you work hella hard for it
and then there's that one competitor
that you know you're like I always beat
this fool out I always work the extra
overtime hours and then somehow because
of favoritism that I got it I could see
why you would be like mother [ __ ] or
what if that guy took his idea Oh
even worse he stole my [ __ ] idea wait
a minute let's hear his side of the
story
where's the a let's interview this guy
the guy that guy you need to know what
yeah why was his anger so justified I
want to know why why did he do this
because I know I used to work for
companies I used to work I [ __ ] hated
my coworkers [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] I was like mad that's why
that's why you get promotions and [ __ ]
but when I look back I was just an
[ __ ] with very like I had a very
bipolar social skill I need to really
[ __ ] liked you or I [ __ ] hated you
I hated the dick writers though yes dick
I'm like some people are just naturally
friendly all overall and although some
people are just naturally dick writers
that's true they're just really good at
sucking yeah like don't just grab a
tease uh you like any any possible way
that [ __ ] makes me wanna be less of a
dick writer cuz I'm like y'all are so
corny like I'm not doing this like not
me fam i'ma just work maybe that's why
we work jobs like this now cuz it's just
not possible I can't do it we didn't
suck our way up the ladder
no but that's like everybody the Kim
Kardashian moment and all JK new thing
what you said all right I forgot who it
was but what do you think yeah when you
were like Kim Kardashian is claiming the
dick ladder oh it was a classic take a
moment like that
I picture someone with like no hands
just [ __ ] dick to jump dick [ __ ]
bobbing competition yeah dick to dick
but that's like all jobs though because
like most job placement isn't really
about your skillset
it's when people hire people it's like
do I want to work with you and see your
face every day
it's you though cuz if I like someone
even if they're talented I mean if I
don't like someone even if they're
talented I don't get what I don't I
don't care exactly I don't care it's
like oh wait you're [ __ ] grandma died
that sucks bro you got you still got to
come to work that's why you even see
these like hot Hollywood auditions and
stuff they have their set people that
they want to hire yeah I mean just
because of their body of work it's just
because they like them they're just
pleasant to work with yeah they're like
oh I like you and that's really about it
that's why they seek networking is super
[ __ ] important mm-hmm so a lot of
these like actors they go in and they're
[ __ ] [ __ ] and you may be skilled
as [ __ ] but they gotta see you on set
every day they don't want to [ __ ] with
you you have it you're annoying like be
god unless you're like somebody like
Denzel or something where you could just
you had that type of like background and
work where you could bring in money but
he also just walks on set makes you fall
in love with them no I she's got I heard
horror stories about him really because
he'll tell the director what to do like
you'll be like hey that's not right and
he'll like stop and then he'll have the
director you know what I mean like
that's he's at that type of power now
though cuz every interview I watch I
question my sexuality of Denzel washes
too much charm too much time for one man
I didn't know he was charming he is
coming out I don't know what I'm like I
know what was like shooting man on fire
you know I know like God he's so
charming like what he licks his chin ooh
what one one show he was on I don't know
what it was that Jimmy Fallon or Jimmy
Kimmel or Jimmy Jimmy someone and then
what some Jimmy Wang who did you want
and they give him on line and the line
is just like basic right like I bought
groceries but then when he says it and
he delivers it it's like bullish it's
crazy you just met your key Bob you
didn't say anything he just kills it he
killed I don't know how to do Denzel but
he says I and you look happier sexier
and thank you and in better shape than
ever
[ __ ] I don't see what the charming man
at all
[Laughter]
wait he does see that all right okay
things like my old black dudes do that
it's like you're in for a treat like all
right okay like dang I yeah okay I feel
like I'm hurting I'm gonna give you a
line and I want you to [ __ ] you sexy it
up then all right Denzel okay here we go
this is the line do you have any more
organic celery do you have any more
organic fire yeah I felt the barrel how
do you even give the sex through that is
it hot in here anymore
Organic that's something I'd like to
learn how do you channel sex through
words all right I don't know how to do
that
I just think about raping they've gotta
start you gotta start the egg wash years
ha lose weight bring in with my eyes did
you see my I looked at your vagina no I
saw eyes now I have to do it for karate
so now it's easy for me ah so I could do
it now cuz I'm forced to yes what do you
mean I can do it no we could win staring
contest cuz I have to do it now for
karate they go you have to look like
look into my eyes because you're not
[ __ ] scared you know you're not [ __ ]
scared then I'm like okay I could do it
and I had to do it for 90 minutes that's
a long [ __ ] time straight into it
that's a long time to my partner's eyes
I just have to stare into the heart
visit every person has a funny feeling
weird
did it feel weird you look into a guy's
eyes are just like
yeah those guys and girls so we just
have to train gotta do it for the karate
let's do it bro
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]